shot clock at seven
[Applause]
Bronson over Jared Allen drills the
three Jalen Brunson with 23 points and
his first playoff game is in Nick New
York ball with a two-point lead Brunson
again working in Osmond with a crossover
dribble now takes the long two and
connects again Brunson with 25 Nicks by
four
fresh 14 seconds
Brunson driving an Osmond floater good
up class for Brunson 27. Park to power
three-pointer in and out part the
offensive rebound back out the Frozen
history
from downtown a 10-point Nick lead
for the lead
Jalen brookson from downtown
you saw the rotation change yes
Bronson gets to the cup
Nicks out to their lead
[Applause]
Randall now holding pass inside Brunson
layup got it and the Knicks Take the
Lead
12 points eight rebounds for conchar
Brunson as we get under the three-minute
mark
looking for some room current shoots and
scores and the game is taught
good priest throws there from John Moran
Brunson steps back jump shot is good
Jalen Brunson two top buckets here and
the game is tied again as we approach
two minutes remaining Morant playing off
the inbounds
R.J Barrett back to Brunson Brunson on
the drive kicks it out reddish a corner
three
Randall has a mismatch
Brunson on the drive gets inside the
floaters up but good and as Brunson once
again hits the floor
Johnson drives
pulls up three-pointer puts it in Jalen
Brunson Nails a three the Russo goes
sliding on his derriere Brunson
trying time again the Knicks three balls
propelling it
is trying to stay in front
Brunson gets in the paint stops falling
away is up it's good Jalen fronts him
with a big bucket it's a one-point game
yeah he's been lethal in the paint
backing in against Moran backs in spins
inside off the class it's good and he
gets knocked down
[Applause]
Brunson double team
Randall hails it back that's all he's
going to see now judson's for free
[Applause]
Brunson three-pointer
ties the game
radish finds Randall now Brunson
Brunson open three puts it in yeah
because he's forcing him right taking
away the left hand of Bronson now he
comes to that Brunson spins leans in
Falling Away got it
production with another clutch bucket
three-point Sixers lead two minutes
remaining there's brookson up in the
left hand Knicks back to a change of the
Night hits with the basketball and a
one-point Advantage there's brookson
who's a scholar athlete true clever
slick watch how he gets into the paint
Kenny cunning
[Applause]
lost it Randall Dives on it balls to
loose Randall the Brunton Brunson throws
it down out of Brunson Brunson on the
drive backing in eight on the shot clock
Clemson spins
oh
it's up by two position is switching
Nick's not getting back after the Nixon
looked like they got a little momentum
back two key plays Brunson fires and
hits a three Caitlyn Brunson with a big
bucket Hill gets into the paint drives
down the lane passes out to Turner they
swing the ball stolen by Brunson Brunson
in the front Court stops inside banks at
home it's a one-point game
coming up on the three minute Mark
another close one to the Knicks at the
guard the Knicks of course just a
mediocre team at home runs in extends
and finishes his Spurs you know the
Knicks are going to go one-on-one they
haven't been dishing the ball this is
Brunson
knocks it down for a career best he's
got 36. Brunson
Frozen Johnson the fade away Allison
see look at the defense by Johnson so
you got to be all over Brunswick you
can't let him do this
you gotta try to force him
[Applause]
self
Brunson five to shoot looking for a
screen find some room right here Brunson
for three
Nick's trying to win their fifth
straight game
runs in the drive continues inside flips
it up and in oh gorgeous move from Jalen
Brunson
Bronson looking
spins against Holliday turns fires
Chemex Galen frontenson does it again
he's got 36. the dispute whether the
Knicks have two or one timeout remaining
as Brunson gets it Brunson drives down
Elaine off the glass it's good
Grimes looking throws it to Robinson
ahead to Brunson Brunson drives pulls up
jumper it's good so they've got to move
the ball don't dribble he pounded it
these guys are doubled in every
possession one Shin fights his way
inside Nick Barrett drives up atase
Wilson waiting for three notchable
get away from the timeline get into the
court yeah five to shoot Brunson again
yes
Duty Hauser has come in for Boston Here
Comes Tatum it's a three he's off
rebound Horford back to Brockton blocked
by Brunson this one's Jalen Brunson look
at this block here
he had two blocks tonight that quickly
will back it out
Clemson's been the go-to Guy crossover
Brunson we're top
George a good Defender Leonard a good
Defender they own the Knicks two top
scorers now but there's
[Applause]
[Music]
scored eight consecutive points here's
Bronson he makes it 10.
magic lead by three
here's Brunson the fourth quarter for
behind the arc
actually Randall on the right elbow is
Bronson from
inside the line
[Applause]
[Music]
here's Brunson nice touch off the glass
45 seconds on the clock Knicks lead the
Magic by one Brunson has been infallible
Brunson gets it off for a Sim slam on
the drive gets inside stops nearly Falls
double team left-handed off the glass
it's good oh a circus shot from Jalen
Brunson
Martin a good Defender that's his Forte
he's on Brunson Brunson Falling Away
puts it up puts it in Jalen Brunson
Brunson drives it all the depot
continues stops puts it up off the class
he banks at home the oak has been
coughing it up this afternoon
[Applause]
turnovers now Brunson throw
[Music]
s
Brunson driving in the front Court
Brunson throws it up
six-point lead with 24 seconds remaining
timeout Denver just over four and a half
remaining Bronson drives goes to the rim
banks at home
previously missing that layup giving
McDaniels the opportunity
Brunson backs in backs in falling away
it's good Jacqueline fronts in a tough
turnaround